Hughes day it's been called the Hughes Bowl
it's had some other names as well and uh Dana
we've got three of the best young players in the
NHL going head-to-head tonight Quinn Hughes Jack
Hughes and Luke Hughes speaking about a show it
should be a great one on the ice it's all about
the Hughes Brothers Quinn Jack and Luke playing
in the same NHL game for the first time who now
gets it behind the goal Fe back to Quinn Hughes
Hughes fakes the pass takes a look lets it Go
Vana stick save F on the rebound he wasn't eased
in with 13 or 14 sheltered minutes Jack Hughes
spins away from Tyler Meers Hughes to the front
here's H he answers Eric Hollis scores in his
return and the devils are back out in front this
is just such a headyy play from Jack Hughes he
stops and look at the vision his 22nd assist of
the year he is the first Hughes on the board in
this first meeting of all three Hughes Brothers
Paulo wins it right back he has Hughes behind
him he leaves it for him jack shoots save made by
Denco on the blocker now it's l fugh with it up
top Kevin ball from the blue line to the front
score Jack Hughes puts it in out of the faceof
circle Jack Hughes beats Bluer on the draw and
bler slow getting back to the net bler got to
Shield Jack Hughes from going to the net and
he's all by himself and he pushes it onto his
backand and coming coming into the game leading
the NHL in points per game he's already got two
in the first period and Jim and Ellen Hughes are
hoping everybody gets a bunch of points tonight
but what a an unbelievable night this must be
for them to to see their three boys playing in
the National Hockey League and Jack's on the
board here Quinn had a first period where he
didn't get on the board but in the offensive zone
he starts to roam around it's almost impossible
for the forwards as you see Curtis Lazar get
lost there to stay in front of him because he
skates so well look how much room he covers here
this Puck bounces off the defenseman and causes
all kinds of chaos we've talked a lot about how
Quinn decided over the summer and worked on his
shot about how he needed to shoot it more more
frequently Jack Hughes gets it and delivers it
as much as anybody in the National Hockey League
he shoots it with Pace he shoots it off in stride
came into the game he had 81 shots in just 17
games almost five a game John Marino tries the
other side to P it had it blocked But Here Comes
Jack Hughes into the van Z got on the forehand
could get that one to go but there you saw that
example of the shot mid stri Jack Hughes is out
on the Rush look at him survey the the scene and
then take the puck inside the triangle of where
Tyler Meers stick as he's waiting for Meyers to
turn big stores of Hugh's Brothers tonight but
how many sets of Brothers do you think are the NHL
this season 20 yes 20 where each brothers played
at least one game this season seems kind of crazy
when you actually think about it to Jack Hugh to
the blue line to Luke Hughes now Jack Hughes top
of the circle try to pass across K got to stick on
that he sure keeps the puck in passes it down
now it's thrown across to Jack Hughes puts it
in front shot attempt didn't get through hes on
the rebound Demco able to stop it couldn't cover
it Hees again hit the outside of the post Devil's
coming close and now the pass back is beyond Brad
off to Center and that'll relieve the pressure
of it qu Hughes fights forward in the near Corner
first time tonight I believe that all three
Hughes brothers are on the ice at the same time
and ner wins it back allows the devil to set up 40
seconds left before the period horn comes Jack to
the front to fully stick it but it ruls up top and
Luke Hughes rips it in so now Jack and Luke have
both scored against Quinn and the devil's lead 52
oh look at the parents a broken play and the puck
bounces up in the air Luke Hughes is going to
find it first I guess Jack Hughes is passing it
back it gets deflected by bler on the way back and
this is clean KS the only goal of the frame and it
came with just 34 seconds remaining as Luke Hughes
comes back to him fees the Blue Line Quinn Hughes
takes it wide Hughes in front tip loose CL cander
here's Pon back to Hughes Quinn Hughes rot go
I think ly might have got it in front all the
Hughes are on the board and it's five4 here's
Miller again leaves for Quinn Hughes Myers on
him Hughes nice move of the line tried to shot
that was blocked gets it again Hughes puts
it on goal rebound home scores Quinn Hughes
is an escape artist he's at the blue line
there's nowhere to go man team o Myers's
got to be a lot harder on the play than that
quinnn Hughes blows him off the play there
Myro weighs him by about 40 lbs and as Quinn
Hughes keeps this thing ruling the save off
the rebound and he wedges it not out Miller
shoots it saves an and there's the wh Jasper
brat scores the game's first goal he scores
the game's 11th goal as the Devils win at 65